hello and welcome to this video Jimmy
the same disciplined Egypt I am I don't
know the name right no let's see Quincy
two nums oh maybe I should play the
sameish again in a couple of games
always was quite entertaining but
sometimes you really feel you should
weaken the position so much which is
happening with the the same ish every
game so it's a classical taking away a
long time here not sure can also go
Bishop g5 but I don't mind to do this we
are now with transposing to the zurich
variation the line that of course i have
studied quite a bit in the cause of that
um book project
yeah somewhat strange the time
management here okay well goes to the
aid this is a possible way of playing
even though it has a quite questionable
reputation the night is just not very
well placed and this is downright weird
what is he doing here ok I am preventing
a five-year my F foursquare is weakened
but I don't think that this is
particularly important 85 ok it doesn't
have a clear way of putting the night to
see five so I don't mind that ok so it's
polysemous boop Wow and twisting my
tongue here and this position is more or
less winning for white but you have to
be still careful of course and that
sometimes tend to be too relaxed if I
got get positions like that why does a
pawn up he's got the bishop pair
blackheads no counter play and if I
would have played g5 I would have won a
piece which I simply didn't do I'm not
sure why this is what I'm saying I'm
getting too relaxed if I think that um
my position is excellent i'm just not
paying enough attention to yeah simply
punish play like that ok so let's still
do do the right things here at least try
g5 just win a piece and for a while
already I simply didn't see it f 5 x g5
and then it takes ok ok i can also do
this
okay so yeah I've played this absolutely
terribly and the mean besides the fact
that I could have just one that piece
the position is now somewhat messy which
really shouldn't have happened both
captures make some sense I have to put
pressure on d6 and d5 with night see
form stuff like that okay how to do it I
mean naku b6 doesn't work but maybe I
can play this move yeah this is the
first game of a new session I those
those are always kind of tricky i think
not cannot quite yeah and the right
mindset Chad player to play good moves
sometimes I just do terrible things in
those host games like here it's almost
absolutely not necessary at all that
this game is still going on I could have
just hoping that you want that piece ok
man I still think it's it's it's good
for white taking b7 ok maybe
how to do it it also just take these six
huh what is the deal Queen cannot enter
now taking here doesn't work check to
check is getting them ok I can go to see
five probably yes
okay if he takes there I was thinking g5
but there should be seven don't know but
should be 70 my takes you for why it's
not a good idea g5 Queen takes their
check time morning now that should win I
think it wins Queen takes Queen f6
should win check and he's got this chick
here I'm still not check so didn't see
that correctly i thought if i take hmm
ok
okay have to play move only have 30
seconds left covering the check on jay
and i couldnae two or something check
it's not ideal anyway I needed to need
to play
12 bloody seconds go to the game check
check
three seconds check okay so we will have
at least a draw by getting the e5 pawn
check check check game drama okay that
was one of the worst games i can
remember in recent history I mean this
is simply simply know what to say I
can't just blade you five I simply
didn't think at all I mean ok this is
this hold stuffy in 98 it's just bad and
I mean this what kind of thing is this
night is one h6 and now I simply don't
play g5 and he resigns this is trapped
I'm just a complete [ __ ] yeah instead I
mean he just doesn't do anything about
it yeah and I don't I don't I don't play
it again g5 winning you peace it just it
just total joke yep what I'm doing here
ok me the position is still winning of
course but you can just win a piece yeah
and by now it's just it's just messy
it's just messy stuff very white is
winning again probably with some stuff
taking look everyone that's it's really
a point is to analyze because it's got
so many mistakes this position also
should be just one very easily and yeah
check check
so what is winning here i mean this is
this is also winning check yeah i can
take age five and just continue check
yeah i was getting i was panicking a
little bit here with with no Sun no time
the idea he should win but he blundered
it away again and talk to a lot Jen
charity I don't judge with the time chef
what a bad game but okay it can only be
can only get better let's kick this is
the positive side of such a such a bad
game oh wow thanks for watching